اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
كرديه في ايران ترفض دخول لجنه الامميه
للتحقيق
منتخب الكاميرون يخسر من سويسرا بهدف بقدم
مواطنها الذي يلعب مع الفريق الخاص
ومع تصعيدي انقره في سوريا قصد تتهم
واشنطن بالغذلان ومسكت تتوقع ان لا يقدم
اردوغان على تهديد
ازمات تويتر تنتقل الى اروقه الكونجرس
الامريكي وتؤجج الخلاف بين الديمقراطيين
والجمهوريه
اهلا بكم الى نشره الخامسه من العربيه
نبدا من ايران فما تصاعد الاضرابات في
المدن الايرانيه ردا على عمليه القمع التي
تشونها قوات الامن بحق المحتاجين دعا كتاب
في محافظه كردستان غربي ايران الى استقاله
جماعيه للبرلمانيين تضامنا مع المدن
الكرديه واعلن الموقعون على البيان دعمهم
للمطالب التي وصفوها بالمشروع للمحتاجين
حيث ادانوا عمليات القتل والاعتقالات بحق
المحتاجين السلمي» وتاتي هذه الدعوه من
قبل هؤلاء الكتاب في الوقت الذي طلب فيه
عدد من النواب في رساله مفتوحه الى رئيس
القضاء الايراني طالب باعدام المتظاهرين
المدنيين في اسرع وقت ممكن
هذا وقد استخدم المحتجون سلاح الاضرابات
ردا على حملات القمع التي تمارسها قوات
الامن منذ بدا الاحتجاجات وقد وفقط الصور
مشاركه واسعه من اصحاب المحل التجاريه
الذين اغلقوا ابواب متجيرهم تضامنا مع
المحتجين
[موسيقى]
اشكال اشكال
هذا وقال مفاوض الامم المتحده لحقوق
الانسان فولكر تورك ان ايران لم ترد على
طلب بزياره وفد الاميه اليها لتفقد
الاوضاع
ودعتورك السلطات الايرانيه للتوقف عن
القمع المنهج ضد المحتججي وقال في خطاب
امام مجلس حقوق الانسان التابعه للامم
المتحده ان هناك ازمه حقوق انسان متكامله
الاركان وخاصه في المدن الكرديه حيث ينظر
الوضع هناك بازمات خطيره واضاف ترك ان
هناك ازمه شامله وعلى اعلى المستويات على
صعيدي حقوق الانسان في ايران
اسمي
جدا ما يحدث في ايران مشاهد الاطفال الذين
يقتلون واصور النساء اللواتي يتم ضربهن في
الشوارع والاشخاص المحكومين بالاعدام لقد
راينا موجات من الاحتجاجات في ايران خلال
السنوات الماضيه التي تنادي بالعداله
والمساواه والكرامه حقوق الانسان وقد
قابلت بالعنف والقمع استعمال القوه
المبالغ فيها وغير الضروريه يجب ان يتوقف
العقليه القديمه لاصحاب السلطه في مجالات
الاحتجاجات لا تنفع بل على عكس تماما
تفاقمنا الاوضاع نحن الان نواجه ازمه على
اعلى المستويات على الصعيد حقوق الانسان
في ايران
وزيره خارجيه المانيا الى تشكيلي اليه
الامميه جديده شفافه ومستقل للتحقيق في
انتهاكاته حقوق الانسان في ايران
مكياج
احترام حقوق الانسان والتوقف عن عمليات
القمع العنيفه ضد المتظاهرين وصف الدماء
والقتل واحكام الاعدام والاعتقالات
الواسعه لكن الاجابه الوحيده التي حصلنا
عليها هي المزيد من العنف والمزيد من
القتل ايران ما زال ترفض منح الامم
المتحده والمقرر الخاص لحقوق الانسان
الدخول الى ايران كما سمعنا للتو لذلك
نقترح تشكيل اليه اماميه جديده شفافه
ومستقله للتحقيق في انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
لكي يحاسب كل مسؤول عنها لان الحصانه تمنع
العداله
وفي عقاب قمع المحتاجين بما في ذلك
المناطق الكرديه تعاهد المتحدث باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه نيبرايز تعهد بان
تتحرك بلاده سريعا من خلال اجراءات احاديه
مع شركائها الدوليه
وشدد برايس على ضروره محاسبه ايران على ما
وصفها باعمال العنف الوحشيه ضد شعبها
وخاصه على النساء والفتيات
[موسيقى]
الى شان اخر خسر المنتخب الكاميرونيه امام
نظيره السويسري بهدف دولارات في مستهلي
مشوار الفريقين في مونديال العالم لكره
القدم والتقى المنتخبان ضمن منافسات
الجوله الاولى للمجموعه السابعه في
مونديال قطر 20 22
وقد سجل هدفا اللقاء الوحيد للمنتخب
السويسري مهاجم نادي موناكو بريل ام بولو
وهو كاميروني الاصل حيث رفض الاحتفال
بالهدف في مشهد النادر حينما يسجل لاعب
هدفا في اهم بطوله لكره القدم
في العالم
معي من الدوحه الان لمزيد من المتابع موفد
العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي عبد المحسن ال
وسهلا بك كيف الاجواء من عندك وابرز
مشاهداتك هذا اليوم
[موسيقى]
الثلاثاء
التي
الان في منطقه فيفا وهي المنطقه الرسميه
[موسيقى]
تتواجد فيها كافه الخدمات للجماهير وايضا
الوسائل للترفيهيه الاخرى والحفلات
الغنائيه
حتى الان المباراه
طالب
العقبه كبيره جدا
عن ثلاثه من اسيا السعوديه واليابان كوريا
الجنوبيه همم في همم على الاقل حتى هذه
اللحظه لم تخسر اليابان فازت على يوم
الامس انتصار كبير على المانيا وايضا
السعوديه انتصار كبير على الارجنتين
وكوريا الجنوبيه حتى هذه اللحظه متعادله
همم في استثناء ايضا استراليا التي خسرت
قبل ايام ولكن نتحدث اليوم عن هذه
الامطار التي اتجهت الى الفرق الاقل حظا
طالب واصبح
محطه الانبار
واصبح ايضا تخوف كبيره من هذه
الفرق التي هي اقل حظا
وتقدم مستويات كبيره جدا خلال هذه
المباراه عموما اليوم تنتهي همم الجوله
الاولى بشكل
طالب ام بعد مباريات المجموعه الاخيره
السابعه
البرازيل هذه المباريات عند الساعه 10:00
مساء
المتابعين على تويتر طبع سعودي وهو يلح
علي ان اسالك هذا السؤال عن استعدادات
المنتخب السعودي للمباراه المقبله مع
بولندا وهل يتسنى لكم عبد المحسن مشاهده
تدريبات المنتخب السعودي وكيف هي
المعنويات يساله
في الحقيقه المنتخب السعودي يطالب انا لم
استمع الى الجزء الاول من سؤالك ولكن في
الحقيقه المنتخب السعودي دخل في معسكر
عادي الى معسكري
والامور مغلقه بشكل كامل لا احد يعرف عن
كثيرا عن اوضاع المنتخب السعودي همم
مدرب السعودي هيرفي رونار صحفيه ليوم الغد
ليتحدث فيه
المباراه التي المرتقبه ضد بولندا يوم
السبت ولكن بشكل عام الاجواء في المنتخب
السعودي اجواء احتفاليه رائعه جدا وايضا
تربيه القطط اللاعبين المنتخب السعودي بعد
رده الفعل الكبير ليس فقط من السعوديه
المنتخب
بسرعه كبيره من التفاؤل وايضا حماس بعد
هذه المقاطع كبيره وبرده الفعل الكبيره
جدا من
التاييد الشعبي العربي الكبير للمنتخب
السعودي في التالي لا نتوقع ذلك الا انت
تكون همم الاجواء متفائله وحماسيه
وايجابيه بشكل جميل جدا
من الدوحه العربيه عبد المحسن الحربي شكرا
جزيلا لك عبد المحسن على هذه المتعه
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
ردا على التحركات الاوروبيه بوت يوجه بعدم
تصدير النفط والغاز الروسي الى الدول التي
تضع السقفا للاسعار
اهلا بكم من جديد
من ذلك القت باللائمه على صواريخ الدفاع
الجوي الاجنبيه والاوكرانيه بالتسبب في
اضرار لاحقه الطاقه في العاصمه الاوكرانيه
وقالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها لم توجه
ايضا لاهداف داخل كيف مشيره الى ان اي
اضرار تقع هي نتيجه لسقوط الصواريخ من
انظمه دفاع جوي اجنبيه واوكرانيه في مناطق
السكنيه بالعاصمه الاوكرانيه حسب
التعبيرها
ورغم النفي الروسي الا ان الظلام بات يخيم
على العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف نتيجه الضربات
المكثفه على منشات للطاقه الاوكرانيه حيث
تشاهدت العاصمه اكبر انقطاعا للتيار
الكهربائي منذ دلاع الحرب
التيار الكهربائي انقطع عن اكثر من ثلثي
العاصمه كما بقي جزء كبير من السكان بدون
ماء
وفي ظل فصل شتاء متوقع ان يكون قاسيا جدا
حثت الحكومه الاوكرانيه مواطنيها على
ترشيد استهلاك الطاقه وخاصه التي تشهد
حاليا تساقطا للثلوج ودرجات حراره دون
الصفر مئويه
وفي سياق متصل قال رئيس بلديه كيف ان
الفنيين وعمال الاصلاح يبذلون قصار جهدهم
لاستعاده الطاقه باسرع وقت ممكن كما حذر
الصحيفه واشنطن بوست من كارثه انسانيه في
اوكرانيا تلوح في الافق هذا الشتاء حيث من
المحتمل ان يواجه ملايين الاشخاص ظروفا
مميته بدون كهرباء ولا تدفئه ولاميه
واشارت الصحيفه الى صعوبه اصلاح انظمه
الطاقه الاوكرانيه التي تضررت بعد سته
اسابيع من القصر في المكثف
مضيفه انه لا يوجد لدى المسؤولين المحليين
حل الا عبر حث السكان على الفرار ما سيؤدي
الى ازمه جديده للاجئين في البلدان
الاوروبيه المجاوره
معي من مدينه نيكولايا بالاوكرانيه مراسل
العربيه حذيفه عادل حذيفه جديد المشهد من
ميكو لايف سواء على المستوى الميداني او
على المستوى الحياتي المعيشي تحديدا موضوع
على الكهرباء والطاقه والتدفئه
تحياتي طالب يعني في مدينه نيكلايف تحديدا
عاد التيار الكهربائي قبل حوالي نصف ساعه
فقط منذ الامس بعد الاستهداف الواسعه
النطاق ل 11 ولايه اخرى ب 67 صاروقا روسيا
استهدبيه التحتيه للطاقه وبعد هذه
الصواريخ سقطت في مناطق مهوله بالسكان قتل
نتيجه هذه الاستهدافات عدد من المواطنين
وجرح اخرون الان يتلقون الرعايه الصحيه من
بينهم هنا في مكان ايضا الان بينما نتحدث
وردت الاخبار من اخر صوت همم عن همم
قصف همم استمر او كان 13 مره تم قصف مدينه
اخر سلوى قتل شخص الان قبل قليل في قصف
اخير في مدينه خرسان الوضع طبعا صعب جدا
همم طالب في جميع المدن الاوكرانيه لذلك
الان السلطات الاوكرانيه تحاول ان تبتكر
الحلول ومن ضمن هذه الحلول هي همم عمليه
انشاء او تجهيز همم
مولدات الكهرباء هي عباره عن خيام اا توزع
جغرافيا في المدن في كل مدينه همم تم همم
يعني حوالي في البدايه بدات بحوالي 40 ما
بين 30 الى 40 مركز تم انشاءه اما خيام او
مناطق عباره عن همم مؤسسات لا تعمل في
الوقت الحالي تم تجهيزها بالمولدات وكذلك
بالتدفئه التي تعمل عن طريق مولدات
الكهرباء وتم تجهيز ايضا المكان ليكون
مناسب لاستقبال المواطنين همم هنالك جزئين
من هذه الملاجئ هنالك ملاجئ مؤقتا للاقامه
المؤقته في حال انقطع التيار الكهربائي في
المدينه يمكن للمواطن ان يذهب الى هذا
المرجع هناك يمكن ان يلعب الذي يفقده في
منزله كذلك عن همم يقوم بشحن الهواتف
السياره او المصابيح وما الى ذلك نوع اخر
هو في حاله الاطفاء
هذه للاقامه الطويله حيث يمكن المواطن ان
ان يكون في هذا الملجا لفترات طويله حتى
هذه اللحظه تم تجهيز
3,360 في جميع
3200 عفوا
هذه الاماكن وهذه الخيم وهذه الملاجئ الى
اي مدى يبدو تبدو لك هذه الحلول ناجعه همم
وهل هذا يعني ان ازمه الطاقه والكهرباء
ستطول وستمر طويلا لذلك تلجا السلطات في
كياب الى هذه الحلول
اول مطالب لابد ان اشير الى ان هنالك
ازدحام كبير جدا في هذه المناجم من قبل
المواطنين لان القطوعات تحدث في جميع
المدن اللايف اكثر من 24 ساعه كانت
الكهرباء مقطوعه لذلك المواطنين يذهبون
اليها طلبا للدفء وايضا ل شحن الهواتف
السياره
هنالك يكون صفط طويل في الخارج ينتظر ان
يخرج من يخرج من هناك ثم بعد ذلك ليحل
محله همم الحل هو ليس يعني لا يمكن لا هو
حل غير عملي لا يمكن ان يكون حل مستدام
ولكن له مؤقتا يفي غرض اولا همم عمليه
التواصل المواطنين يقومون بشحن الهواتف من
وجدتهم يعملون هنالك من يعمل همم عن طريق
اون لاين او عن طريق في وضع غير همم
الاتصال لذلك وجدت البعض يعملون داخل هذه
المراكز همم يباشرون اعماله ووجدت بعض
الاخر من الطلاب الذين يدرسون حتى في هذه
الملاهي وكثير من الذين ياتون خاص كبار
السن الذين فق الكهرباء والتدفئه والغاز
في منازلهم ايضا هنالك بعض المراكز التي
توزع لتجهيز الطعام للمواطنين وتقديمه
بشكل مجاني هذه الحلول لا يمكن ان تكون
حلول همم يعني طويله ال ال العجل او مستمر
ولكنها تفي بالغرض في الوقت الحالي سميت
طبعا بي لن نكسر يعني هذا الاسم الذي
اطلقته اطلق على المبادره والديها موقع
الكتروني يمكن المواطنين ان يدخل ليعرفوا
اقرب نقطه من طيب همم
وعاطفيا همم حذيفه شكرا جزيلا لك على كل
هذه المتابعه انتقل اعزائي المشاهدين الى
الحدود البيلاروسيا الاوكرانيه ينضم اليه
من هناك مفرد العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد
الطقس بالطبع عاصف ومثلج همم عبد الجواد
اهلا وسهلا بك كيف هي الصوره من عندك وهل
الامور تنبؤ بالاسوا كما تقول بعض المواقع
على هذه المنطقه الحدوديه الاوكرانيه ال-
البلا الروسيه ام لا يجب تضخيم الامور ما
زالت هادئه وهادئه جدا
مرحبا طالب نعب بالفعل توتر كبير وحاله من
الغليان على الشريط الحدودي الفاصل بين
بيلاروسيا واوكرانيا ساضع صوره تتحرك طالب
وطري البشه هنا نحن الان مع كاميرا
العربيه نقف على نقطه حدوديه طبعا ليست هي
ببعيده كثيرا عن الحدود البولنديه وهذه
النقطه التي نشاهدها في الكاميرا الان هي
نقطه الحدود الواصله للاراضي الاوكرانيه
كنا نحاول الاقتراب من هناك ولدينا
التصريح الكامل لكن للاسف طالب طبعا
الاتصالات لا تعمل ونحن مضطرون للوقوف في
هذه النقطه طالب طبعا الوضع على الحدود هو
اشبع بالقنبله الموقوطه طبعا هي تكتك على
شفاء الانفجار طبعا اسلاك شائكه لم يعني
كما اعتدنا على الحدود طالب كانت اسلام
شائكه ورموز طبعا تحدد حدود الدوله لكن
الوضع اليوم هو اكبر من ذلك طبعا هناك
تعزيزات لقوات حرس الحدود البيلاروسيين
كما شاهدنا يقابلها تواجد عسكري اوكراني
مدجج بالمعدات الثقيله في ظل الظروف
الحاليه كما نشاهد تقوم ميسكو وهي حليفه
موسكو برصد التغييرات المتقلبه حاله
استنفار طبعا وحضور سريع للرد في حال حدوث
اي مشاكل كبيره طبعا خاصه انها قامت بدعوه
يعني يعني همم عناصر حرس الحدود
الاحتياطيين وجاءت وعادت بهم الى تلك
المنطقه طالب طبعا كما نلاحظ في تلك
المنطقه يقوم الجانب الاوكراني بوضع خط
فاصل حدودي من الاسمنت ومن الاسلاك الشركه
يعيد للاذهان بعض الشيء طبعا همم قضيه
جدار برلين الذي انقذ قسم العالم الى
نصفين في تلك الوقت وانتهى بالدم على ما
يبدو طالب الاستفزازات كبيره خاصه من قبل
الجانبين او من خلال
ولكن عندما تجول في المناطقيه عندما تجول
على المناطق الحدوديه المحاديه هل هنالك
حشود عسكريه اسلحه ثقيله ام لا يعني
والسؤال هل تتحضر بيلاروسيا فعليه لدخول
هذه الحرب يعني في قرار بدخول الحرب املا
لا يجب ايضا تضخيم همم الامور وكل ما يطلق
من تصريحات من قبل ما نسكافيه فقط للتحذير
فقط
طالب يعني حالو هذه النقطه الحدوديه التي
اقف عليها يشبه حال باقي النقاط يعني
والتصريح الذي حصلنا عليه على ما يبدو
يصلنا للنقطه الابسط من حيث وجود التواجد
العسكري ما شاهدناكم وما شاهدناه هناك هو
تواجد مكثف للقوات البيلاروسيه في هذا
المكان طبعا قوات حفظ السلام وقوات مراقبه
كل ما يحدث باعتبار ان طائرات مسيره تظهر
في الجو يتم اسقاط البعض منها هناك بعض
الكاميرات تقوم بالتصوير على مدار الاربع
والعشرين ساعه شاهدنا طبعا مدرعه واحده
فقط على الجانب الاوكراني طالب هي مدرعه
واحده فقط لكن الشريط الحدودي كما يبدو
يعني هو مقدم على مرحله التصعيد كبيره
طالب في حال انفجرت هذه القنبله سيتحول
هذا الشريط الى الشريط بين روسيا
واوكرانيا طبعا
سقوط لقذائف والصواريخ كما هو متوقع في
على هذه الجبهه لكن حتى هذه الوضع كما
تلاحظ ان الان اقف في هذا المكان لا وجود
لاي شخص ولي اي سياره في هذا المكان تعمل
الكاميرات على مدار الساعه والطريق مغلق
بين البلدين على جميع السكان قال من
الحدود البلاريوسيه الاوكرانيه مفرد
العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد شكرا جزيلا لك
جواد على هذه المتابعه
[موسيقى]
هذا واجهه الرئيس الروسي
بعدم تصدير النفط والغاز الى الدول التي
تدعم وضع سقف لاسعار الطاقه وقال المتحدث
باسم الكربلا انه بناء على توجيهات الرئيس
بوتين لن يتم تزويد الدول التي تدعم هذا
التوجه بالنفط والغاز الروسيه
هذا وقالت رئيسه مفوضيه الاوروبيه او ارسل
لاين خلال زياره الى فلندا ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي يعد حزمه تاسعه من العقوبات ضد
روسيا ردا على هجومها على اوكرانيا وذكرت
فندق لاين في مؤتمر صحفي ان اوروبا تعمل
جاهده على استهداف روسيا في المجالات التي
تؤلمها وذلك لتقويه قدرتها على مواصله
الحرب على اوكرانيا مشيرتان الى اتفاق
قريب حول وضع سقف عالمي لسعر النفط الروسي
مع مجموعه السبع والشركاء الرئيسيين
الاخرين
نشاط الخامس مستمره فيها ايضا
روسيا تؤكد ان اي عمليه بريه تركيه في
سوريا ستزيد من التوتري في المنطقه
اهلا بكم جديد حدثت وزاره الخارجيه
الروسيه من ان اطلاق تركيا لعمليه عسكريه
بريه في سوريا سيزيد من التوتر في المنطقه
واضافت الخارجيه الروسيه ان العمليه
البريه ستؤدي ايضا الى زياده نشاط
المسلحين في حال اقدام تركيا على تنفيدها
هذا وافاد مراسل العربيه ان وفد امريكيا
سيلتقي اليوم قيادات بقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه لبحث وقف الهجمات التركيه
واوضح مراسلنا ان منسقه مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي للشرق الاوسط برت ماجور هو من
يقوده جهود التهدئه بين قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وتركيا
هذا ويستمر القصف التركي على شمال سوريا
حيث افاد المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان
بسقوط اربعه قتله و13 جريحا جراء القصف
التركي على مناطق نفوذ قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه شمال الحسكه القصف التركيه
اجبر احدى عشره منظمه دوليه محليه ومحليه
لتعليق اعمالها في مخيم الهول بسبب
الغارات التركيه ومع تصعيد في الازمه عبر
تحذيرات تركيا بهجوم بريه وشيك على شمال
سوريا اتهمت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
واشنطن بالخضر بسبب معتبر خجول من واشنطن
تجاهها العمليه العسكريه المرتقبه في شمال
سوريا واكتفت واشنطن بادانه التصعيد
التركي في سوريا وقال ناطق باسم وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه نيد برايس ان بلاده
تتفهم ان لدى تركيا مخاوف امنيه فيما
يتعلق بالارهاب لكن في الوقت
لديها مخاوف وجديه ازاء تاثير التصعيد في
سوريا على المدنيه
معن الجانب الروسي فاعلن المبعوث الروسي
الى سوريا الكسندر لافرنتير ان موسكو
مستعده لتوفير منصه للقاء الرئيسيين
السوري بشار الاسد والتركي رجب طيب
اردوغان مشددا على ان بلاده حاولت اقناع
تركيا خلال محادثاتنا بالامتناع عن عمليه
قد تؤدي الى تصعيد في الشرق الاوسط باكمله
على كل مزيد من المتابعه معي من اربيل
الان استاذه الفلسفه السياسيه في جامعه
كوريا الدكتور سربست نبي دكتور نبيل اهلا
وسهلا بك الاكراد وتحديدا قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه يخشون من ان تكون واشنطن قد
اعطى الضوء اخضر
لانقره للبدء بعمليه عسكريه بريه واسعه
النطاق في الشمال السوري هل تعتقد ان
واشنطن اعطت مثل هذا الضوء او لنقل تردد
عن اي عمليه عسكريه تركيه مرتقبه
مساء الخير مساء النور انا استبعد ان تكون
واشنطن قد منحت الضوء الاخضر
لتركيا للقيام بعمليه بريه العمريه البريه
ستكون عواقبها كارسيه على المنطقه من
الجهه الامنيه
ستطلق
دبابير الارهاب من جحورها في المنطقه تعيد
القاره في العراق وسوريا الى ما قبل الى
احد 2015 ولهذا السبب امريكا الولايات
المتحده لديها قلق جدي بهذا الخصوص لكن في
العمق انا براي هناك همم هناك مقايضات
خفيه اذا تاملنا ساعات الاخيره تصريحات
المتبادل
موقع ايضا بين
النظامين السوري والتركي وهذه الضربات
جاءت لتسرع عمليه التفاهم بين النظامين من
جانب اول صرح المبعوث الروسي الى سوريا
بان تركي ان هناك تفاهمات تامه بين تركيا
بشان
مناطق خفض التصعيد وان تركيا ستفتح المجال
امام همم امام الطائرات الروسيه القدوم
الى سوريا همم
نحن نعلم اصلا المجال الجوي بس دكتور انت
دكتور انت تعرف هل
الفكره بس يمكن ان يتم كل ذلك بدون غطرف
من قبل واشنطن وهذا ما يفسر ربما تصريحات
اكثر من مسؤول في قوات خاصه
دعنا دعنا دعنا من تصريحات قياده قست هذه
هذه تصريحات عاطفيه لا تفيد ولا ولا تغني
يعني المساله في الجواهر هناك تفاهم حول
الهيمنه على الاجواء السوريه بين الروس
والولايات المتحده ال الروس راديو
بالهيمنه يسيطره الولايات المتحده على
الاراضي السوريه في شمال والشمال الشرقي
وانت تحت تكون تحت المقابل القبول بان
تكون الاجواء تحت السيطره من سمح بطائرات
التركيه بالقصف في هذه بهذا الشكل من
الهمجيه هم الروس في الدرجه الاولى
الرومانعون برا نعم لكنهم يسمحون جوه
وهناك امر ينبغي ان ننتبه ان الضربات بنك
الاهداف التي تم تنفيذها خلال اليومين
الفائتين ما كان ممكن ان يلحق هذا الضر لو
لم يكن هناك تنسيق امني واستخبارات الدقيق
هذه المراكز النفطيه المنشات النفطيه
البنيه التحتيه لا يعلم بها اسرارها
وخفاياها الا الخبراء الروس والنظام
وبالتالي هناك من قدم لهؤلاء الداتا
وخارطه بكل هذه المنشات لا يخرج عن امرين
اما هما الرؤوس او النظام وفي الغالب كلا
الطرفين لحرمان سكان المنطقه من الموارد
الطبيعيه الاقتصاديه من الموارد المعيشيه
من التدفئه من الوقود الى اخره هذه
الهمجيه هي ما تثبت ان النظامين السوري
والتركي طيب
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من اربيل اسامه فلسفه
السياسيه في جامعه كويت الدكتور نبيل شكرا
جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
لهم ماسك على شركه تويتر الى الصدام
الحزبيه
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في السياسه
الداخليه الامريكيه
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي تعد احد مظاهر
التفاعل في اطار ثوره التكنولوجيا لكنها
تلعب دورا ايضا في عالم السياسه منصه
تويتر دليل واضح
منذ استحواذي الين ماسك على تويتر فتح باب
وجدل واسع بين مستخدم
[موسيقى]
على الصعيد السياسي اجج الصدامه الحزبي في
واشنطن بين الحزبين الديمقراطي والجمهوري
مع اختلاف نقاط التركيز بينهما
[موسيقى]
ايمان
فيهم الرئيس الامريكي
موقع تويتر في الاونه الاخيره ويقول بعض
الديمقراطيين انها قد تعرض قدره المنصه
على تامين البيانات الشخصيه لمستخدمها
للخطا
[تصفيق]
مجلس النواب المحتمل العام المقبل فيقولون
ان الديمقراطيين يلاحقون ماسك بسبب
استعداده لمنح المحافظين صوتا على المنصه
ورددوا بان الانتقادات الديمقراطيه هي
محاوله مستتره للقضاء على الاصوات
المحافظه على الموقع وحجب ما اعتبروه حريه
التعبير سعيو ايلون لحريه التعبير وتهديد
مباشر لحزب الديمقراطي وحلفائه في وسائل
الاعلام القديمه بينما يهاجم الديمقراطيون
اي جهد لاعطاء الامريكيين صوتا اقوى سيكون
الجمهوريون يقضينا ضد التواطئ بين شركات
التكنولوجيا الكبرى وهذه الاداره
صحيفه وول ستريت جورنال حذرت من انه
اصطدام قد ينذر بمزيد من الاستقطاب حول
الانترنت ودوري الحكومه في تنظيمه تصاعدات
في السنوات الاخيره دعوات للكونجرس لتحسين
حمايه الخصوصيه وتخفيف هيمنه شركات
التكنولوجيا العملاقه عبر تحديث القانون
الذي يحميها من المسؤوليه عن محتوى الطرف
الثالث
مجددا في اكثر من خبير في موضوع مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي يتحدث يعني عن ان
الاجواء المحيطه منصه تويتر همم تفيد او
تمبي بان المنصه ايه الى الافلاس تماما
همم هل سمت مؤشرات يعني يمكن لحظها همم
بهذا الاتجاه ام لا كل هذا الكلام مجرد
هواجس رافي
نعم يا طالب الافلاس بكل تاكيد هو موضوع
وارد اذا لم يتم التقليس وتخفيف من تكاليف
هذه الشركه الي وصلت سابقا الى 6 مليار
دولار في السنه الواحده ويجب ان نتذكر
جميعا انه الى الماكس ماسك هو ورث شركه
عليها ديون تقدر بثلاثه عشر مليار دولار
يعني فقط لدفع هذه
المصاريف القروض والديون مع الفوائد تصل
الى واحد بلياردو لاربي السنه الواحده
وهذا حمى الكبير على الى الماسك والشركه
فلهذا السبب نرى ان هو يحاول الاستغناء عن
الكثير من الموظفين ليوفر تقريبا همم 800
ل 900 مليون دولار في السنه الواحده الى
مصر يبحث عن حلول لتخفيف من تكاليف هذه
الشركات هناك فكره لنقل الى تكساس من هناك
يعني همم قد ياخذ خصومات كبيره في الضرائب
وايضا هناك همم موضوع الاشتراكات الشهريه
للمستخدمين سيكون ايضا وارد جديد لهذه
الشركه اما الاعلانات اللي هي 90% من
الواردات هذه الشركه واللي الان تعاني
منها تويتر بشكل كبير 4 مليون دولار تخسر
تويتر يوميا بسبب تراجع المعلنين في
الاسبوعين الماضيين فدي كل تاكيد في العشر
سنوات الماضيه ثمان سنوات منهم لم تجني
هذه الشركه ارباح فلهذا السبب الموضوع
مقلق جدا بس رافي في مفارق يعني في مفارقه
هنا طيب همم مشهد انه لهم ماسك همم يطرد
ويصرف الكثير من الموظفين وفي المقابل
للاعلانات الان على الشركه انه تويتر فتحت
باب التوظيف وفي فرص عمل وفي ناس همم
مطالبات همم هل هنالك اقبال وفق مشاهداتك
وما هي الشروط الان للتوظيف في تويتر التي
وضعها الى مصر
بالبدايه موضوع الوظائف الجديده الموضوع
مبكر جدا ولكن نعم تويتر الان تفتح
الابواب لوظائف جديده ولكن تقتصر على
قسمين قسم الهندسه والبرمجيات وقسم
التسويق يجب ان نعرف انه هناك تراجع كبير
من الشركات والمعلمين فهو بحاجه الى
مسوقين جدد فلهذا السبب هو يبحث عن على
وظائف او على اشخاص جدد وفي نفس الوقت
يحاول تفادى من اعطال تقنيه لجذب هؤلاء
المعلنين هو غرد قبل ساعات قائلا انه خطاب
الكراهيه تراجعت الى الثلث الموقع سيكون
اسرع يحاول بكل الطرق لجذب المعلنين
مجددادا من مسافر سيسكو مراسل العربيه
شكرا جزيلا لك رافعه على كل هذه المتابعه
مع اختفاء بعض العلامات التجاريه لعبوبات
الارز في الاسواق في مصر اصبح من الصعب
على المستهلكين الحصول على احتياجاتهم
اليوميه حيث بات التجار اما يعرضون كميات
محدوده لكل زبون او يرفعون السعر ما اثار
استياء من قبل المستهلكين
وعمر حامد سوداني مقيم في مصر وهو الاخر
وعان من ازمه شح الارز في المتاجر المصريه
ولكنه يفضل البحث عن البديل بدلا من
التعرض للاستغلال في بعض المحلات
بسعر طبعا اعلى لكن ما قاعدين نزعل منهن
احنا اه يعني لما نكون غير متوفر بنخلينا
نشوف اي حاجه
همم والله
الخبز العادي اختفت اصناف من الارز بعدما
فرضت الحكومه سعر بيع للمستهلك بدا انه لم
يرق لكثير من المنتجين وهو ما عزاه البعض
للجشع بينما تحدث اخرون عن عدم جدول توريد
بهذه الاسعار بيجيب برز درجه اولى نسبه
الكسر قليله قوي في وبعدين بيعملوا تغليف
جيد جدا وبعدين عندهم جهاز توزيع طبعا
عربيات وسواقين ومندوبين فطبعا لازم السعر
يبقى عالي معهم الحكومه لما حدد لهم السعر
هم حسوا بالخساره ان هم يعني هي مش الربح
بتاعهم هيقل فامتنعوا عن البيع وفي بعض
المتاجر تم اخفاء الارز عمدا لرفع اسعار
ايه بينما رفض البعض وبيع كميات كبيره حتى
لا يساهم في احداث ازمات وفضل ان يبيع
الارز للزبائنه المستديمين فقط وهذا انسحب
ايضا على المتاجر المملوكه للدوله التي
رات ان تتدرج في الطلب حتى لا يحدث تخزين
بدون سبب فبدات في لعب دور التاجر المرجح
مواطن بياخذ اللي هو عايزه بس في حدود
المعقول يعني احنا عارفين حضرتك بتخش
تشتري من عندنا في الاسبوع 5 كيلو ارز اما
نيجي واخذ 20 25 كيلو يقول لك اسف انت لا
تاخد خمسه كيلو بتوعك عشان غيرك يلا عشان
ما نسببش ازمه في الاخر
هو توضح هذه اللقطات التي نشرتها وزاره
الداخليه المصريه هي مها بالقاء القبض على
من يقوم بحجب الارز طبقا لقرار مجلس
الوزراء الذي اعفى من العقوبه كل من يقوم
بالاعلان عن مخزوناته وابلاغها لاداره
التموين المحليه تامر نصره العربيه
القاهره
نشط الخامسه المفصله وفين يكن بها من
العربيه اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه
الله وبركاته
[موسيقى]